bonsoir monsieur cormier ces filières
vous êtes pdg on se dit ça juste avant
d'entrer en ondes depuis un peu plus de
six ans et depuis votre arrivée je
regardais l'actif est passé d'à peu près
250 à 400 milliards de dollars il ya eu
la pandémie beaucoup de travailleurs en
télétravail
six ans plus tard ou s'envoient des
jardins aujourd'hui bah écoutez vous
l'avais dit à une croissance extrêmement
rapide dans tous nos secteurs d'activité
que ce soit les activités bancaires
l'assurance vie l'assurance de dommages
à travers le québec à travers le canada
cinquante cinq mille employés donc ce
n'est pas pour rien qu'on appelle ceux
de mouvement desjardins le mouvement est
en santé les gens ont confiance en
mouvement desjardins nos résultats
d'affaires sont à la hauteur des
attentes alors moi je pense que le
mouvement desjardins et cette
institution alors que les gens sont
fiers qui est un phare au québec au
canada et qui va continuer à croître
dans les prochaines années bien sûr
toutes les institutions et d appuyer les
gens durant la pandémie loving crise de
l'inflation en tout cas une forte
inflation on craint une récession est ce
que vous êtes encore en mode aide pour
mon écoute et on est en mode où on
identifie actuellement nos membres aux
particuliers et aux entreprises qui
pourraient avoir des difficultés selon
nous donc les gens qui ont en effet des
hypothèques dans les dernières années
les gens qui ont en effet des prêts aux
entreprises dans certains secteurs
d'activité où on pense qu'ils vont être
plus impact à court terme on est déjà
listé ces gens-là et nogent encaissés
dans nos centres d'affaires entreprises
vont entrer en contact pour juste voir
parce qu'il ya des besoins de soutien
des besoins d'être des conseils
financiers donc on est très proactifs
actuellement on a commencé au cours des
dernières semaines et on va continuer
dans les prochains mois est ce que vous
avez comme les banques mis le prix des
provisions pour mauvaises créances
éventuelles oui ça fait partie de nos
résultats trimestriels on est toujours
en train d'analyser ça et ça c'est
beaucoup en fonction des facteurs
économiques inflation taux de chômage et
trimestre après trimestre on ajuste en
conséquence on en avait pris beaucoup
durant la pandémie
provisions qui ne se sont pas
matérialisées parce que ça n'a pas été
aussi mal qu'on aime anticiper donc on a
déjà de très bonnes réserves chez
desjardins donc malgré ce qu'on peut
voir dans les prochaines prochains mois
comme perspectives économiques le môme
est extrêmement solide actuellement mais
quand on revoit les taux d'intérêt au
bout un thé puis demain matin la banque
du canada va probablement augmenter de
50 à 75 points de base son taux
directeur ce qui affecte bien sûr le
taux préférentiel est ce que est ce
qu'une institution desjardins en
profitent de cette hausse des taux ou au
contraire les provisions pour mauvaises
créances puis le ralentissement de
l'économie affectent votre vote vous
arrache drapeau la rentabilité mais
ralentit bien vos affaires dans un
mouvement comme desjardins on est
tellement diversifiée comme activité que
parfois la hausse de taux d'intérêt peut
paraître favorable parce que les taux
hypothécaires sont plus élevées pour
dire voilà desjardins va faire plus
d'argent mais d'autres fois on est un
assureur alors actuellement la répare
une automobile une automobile est brisé
le cou a besoin d'une réparation ça nous
coûte beaucoup plus cher les pièges chez
desjardins donc l'inflation pénalise
desjardins donc quand je regarde en
moyenne longue et difficile
d'aujourd'hui dit robin la hausse de
taux d'intérêt elle est hyper favorable
pour desjardins parce qu'il ya une forte
proportion de nos activités qui sont en
assurance et l'inflation vient affecter
nos résultats est ce que vous préparez
une récession au québec sq ont pris part
le sait que dans le premier semestre de
2020 trop on se prépare clairement un
ralentissement économique est-ce que ça
va être qu'une mégots récession puisque
ça va être léger récession est ce que ça
va être un faire un ralentissement s'est
pas totalement clair aujourd'hui on
parle de légère récession mais on se
prépare quand je vous disais qu'on
appelle nos membres qu'on a fait des
listes qu'on regarde avec nous mêmes
entreprises des secteurs d'activité plus
plus plus plus à risque on est pro
actifs par rapport à saxon vous partez
en tournée il ya beaucoup de gens en
tournée de ces jours ci du côté
politique vous les mêmes raisons pas
pour les mêmes raisons pour quelles
raisons pourquoi vous allez rencontrer
les jeunes surtout au cours des
prochains mois dans différentes régions
du québec parce que je veux les entendre
je veux les écouter moi je considère que
nos jeunes ont subi un coup énorme
durant la pandémie est isolé est tout
seul dans son sous-sol pas avoir ses
collègues ses amis à l'école pas
d'activités sportives pourtant pour le
pdg de desjardins soit parce qu'ils sont
l'avenir du québec tous les problèmes
qu'on discute lors de la campagne
électorale ce sont des jeunes de 25 ans
qui vont les régler dans les dix quinze
vingt prochaines années on a besoin de
main d'oeuvre on a besoin
d'entrepreneurs faut leur faire une
place fuller d'un une voix au chapitre
alors c'est pour ça que moi comme pdg
dans le cadre de mes fonctions j'ai
utilisé la tribune que j'ai pour les
écouter puis pour essayer humblement de
leur faire encore plus classe dans
société
le vol de données la fuite de données ça
a occupé une bonne partie de vos six ans
de mandat ça a commencé en 2019 et une
entente à l'amiable au début de l'été on
parle de 200 millions $ qui sera
l'entente est de 200 millions le
processus d'indemnisation commence en ce
moment on en est où le processus dans le
fond il a débuté à la ja peut-être trois
quatre semaines on est dans l'envoi de
documentation des lettres aux personnes
ça devrait se terminer à la mi octobre
il ya un administrateur indépendant
rice pointe qui administre le tout est à
partir de la mi-octobre mais là on va
être capable d'entamer les démarches
pour les remboursements mais c'est clair
que ça va s'échelonner sur 1 2 3 1 le
seroc sur gens vont voir ça peut aller
jusqu'à 1000 dollars si je me trompe pas
l'indemnisation pour certaines personnes
vraiment qu'ils ont été victimes de vols
de données que ceux ci ils vont voir cet
argent là à quel moment mais en
provenance a varié en 2023 et 2025 26
hockey parce que les réclamations vont
se faire auprès de l'administrateur qui
va traiter un peu tout ça en fonction de
la volumétrie et par la suite on va
faire les remboursements en conséquence
vous qu'est ce que vous avez appris de
sites de cette mésaventure
qui a fait la manchette depuis 2010 9
qui a inquiété beaucoup de gens
également qu est ce que vous avez appris
comme dirige deux choses la première
c'est que les gens au québec ont
maintenu leur confiance en des jardins
et ça je ne remercierai jamais assez nos
membres et nos clients vous avez eu des
critiques quand même mais écoutez il
on voit que depuis 2010 9 c'est arrivé
dans malheureusement d'autres
entreprises puis c'est un risque qui
aujourd'hui est une réalité dans tous
les secteurs d'activité alors ce que je
dis c'est un les gens ont confiance en
eux la marque est forte puis les gens
ont construit vous avez vu les chiffres
que vous parliez tantôt 250 à 400
milliards d'actifs deuxièmement mais
c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui desjardins a
créé un bureau de sécurité 1100
personnes ont mis en place plusieurs
mesures de sécurité parmi les meilleurs
dans l'industrie est ce que j'ai retenu
c'est que la cyber sécurité s'ils ont
des principales et risquent leur vie au
jour d'hui sur ces alors il faut être
vigilant est ce que vous êtes protégé a
jamais de ça est ce que ça n'arrivera
plus j'ai déjà ma écoutez j'ai compris
avec tous les spécialistes que j'ai
rencontrés puis toutes les autres chefs
d'entreprise qui j'ai parlé que le
risque zéro malheureusement n'existe pas
il ya des gens qui se lèvent le matin à
travers le monde et qui veulent attaquer
des entreprises qui veulent attaquer des
individus et à l'ère des technologies
notre travail à nous c'est de protéger
sa 24e 24 7 jours sur 7 c'est pour ça
qu'on a créé un bureau de la sécurité
etc à tous les jours on vise à voir des
meilleures pratiques mais à tous les
jours malheureusement ya des gens qui
eux se lève en rouleaux faire du mal
guy cormier merci beaucoup c'est un
plaisir de vous recevoir c'était très
agréable merci bien pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit